[Music]
so earlier this week nick bosa admitted
to espn that he went back to his twitter
page and deleted any tweets that would
indicate any type of political leaning
specifically support of the president
donald trump because as bosu said i may
end up in san francisco
i
and and everybody just kind of accepted
that like oh okay that makes sense well
i i i don't get it i don't understand
why
anyone should be compelled look you're
using it as a personal platform people
express all sorts of views there we're
allowed as americans to have these views
why does anybody feel compelled these
aren't offensive statements this isn't
like the josh allen tweets that surfaced
last year that maybe he should have
scrubbed in advance and this isn't the
musings of a dumb kid and plenty of dumb
kids say dumb things this is a
personally held political view why
should he feel compelled to conceal it
just because he's entering the nfl i
don't get it and and i don't care what
your view is i think people should be
allowed to have the views and express
the views whatever the views may be am i
wrong
yeah you are wrong i mean would you
would you go into a job interview and
start talking politics you wouldn't no
way and and i'm not saying i'm not
saying different disgusting no that
he's in a job interview right now he is
he is he is uh all these teams are
looking at him and trying he's not going
in he's not going in with a maga hat on
these i understand mike but every little
piece matters because people have
personal bias no matter what they have
their own viewpoint they see someone
it's no different than if if joey boser
or nick bosa said hey listen i'm going
to delete all the pictures of me
chugging beer in college because when
someone when a scout's looking at him
when a gm's looking at him whether they
will admit it or not they will have a
personal bias towards his political
views towards whether he parties towards
all these things that make him up as a
person and to eliminate it as much as
that as possible so that he gets hired
just for football that's a smart move by
him honestly i i i'm not saying that
it's it's wrong for him to like i'm not
saying it's right or wrong that he has
to delete the tweets or he shouldn't
it i'm just saying that when you are
going to get a job when you're trying to
have a new employer hire you for your
services and get the top dollar to
eliminate all the personal bias that
someone could have against you is a
smart decision
yeah i look at it this way i'm one of
the top prospects in the draft draft me
or don't and if you don't one of your
competitors will here
you are i'm coming to play football i'm
here to play football if you don't want
me don't draft me
mike if the k if if i told you you had
the difference of making you know two
million dollars or five million dollars
or it keeps going up and up and i said
hey mike maybe delete a couple tweets
from sophomore year of college you would
delete those tweets so fast so fast you
can sit here today and pretend that you
wouldn't but if i told you a one or two
tweets could be the difference of a
million dollars
those tweets would be gone before the
million dollars even got out of my mouth
but big cat i don't understand
look the idea that bosa came out and
said i've deleted my tweets supporting
the president because i may end up in
san francisco it's not gonna
how did oh the 49ers because the tweets
aren't there they don't know about the
issue they know about the issue he's
talking about it openly all right well
yeah obviously saying it openly after
that that's a different story he
probably should have just deleted him
and forgot about him but i i'm just
saying if you have the opportunity to to
eliminate even a small doubt in
someone's mind that could make you
millions and millions and more dollars
i'd do it in a second i would you would
i wouldn't no i wouldn't because here's
the thing if you're going to make
decisions about football players based
on those issues you're going to have a
crappy football team here's where it
matters here's where it matters here's
what let me finish
i want to play for a team that is a good
organization that is going to win and
the more the team wins and the more i
contribute the better i am because i'm
going to get paid a hell of a lot more
on the back end you can't be only
thinking about the first contract the
differences between the draft picks and
how much they make it's not what it used
to be it's packed together a lot more
tightly it's not like when the
difference between one and two and three
and four was multiple multiple millions
of dollars that's the way it was
pre-2011
right now in the nfl the focus is your
second contract and i would rather play
for a good team where i'm going to
flourish and thrive and they have good
football players and they don't care
about this extraneous crap and i can go
there and be a great player and i can
play in january people can see me play
and then i'm going to get paid a bunch
of money either by my current team or
somebody else it's the focus on the
second contract and this obsession with
getting drafted as high as possible is a
mistake i'd rather get drafted lower by
a team that gets it than drafted higher
by a team that doesn't and if that team
is making decisions about whether or not
i support donald trump on my twitter
page that team doesn't get it
how many guys in the first round if you
go through the years
get their second contract that big
contract you're talking about
what is it what i mean what would you
guess half half right okay so yeah i
care what my first contract is i care
about the difference of ten million
dollars and eight million dollars that
makes a difference to me if he slides
five picks or six picks i'm not saying
he that would even be the case in this
situation but to say that you don't care
what your first contract is and the
fully guaranteed money and the fact that
that could set you up and your family up
for life i'm saying i'm serious it's not
that's not the difference it used to be
it's not you you're factually incorrect
it is not the difference it used to be
and the bigger play is setting yourself
up for contract number two and i would
much rather go later as i said with a
good organization that's going to put me
in position to get a bigger second
contract than to get a few extra million
on the front end but be at an
oh oh well i see you're you're in a you
i see on your twitter page that you like
beer we can't have that here i mean well
who's making football decisions based
upon any of this crap anyway these are
football players so i i thought we we
take this this whole draft process and
we try to morph it into a normal job
interview it is not a normal job
interview there's nothing normal about
it these are football commodities
they're looking for guys who can play
football period and all this other crap
should not matter
all right you're wrong and i'm right no
no no just saying it doesn't make it so
yeah i have put you in a box i have your
roster
and i have nailed it shut and if you're
nice i may put in a hole so you can
breathe we'll be back with another hour
of pro football talk live right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports